qui a fait des sciences sociales ou de
la sociologie connaît pierre bourdieu et
son concept d'habitus qu'il a formulées
dans son oeuvre la distinction souvent
ce que les élèves retiennent de la
distinction une pierre bourdieu c'est
ceux ci considérant finalement que
pierre bourdieu dans ce tableau a fixé
les goûts de chaque classe sociale pour
l'éternité
rien n'est moins faux évidemment puisque
le sociologue mettait lui même en garde
contre les effets négatifs que peut
avoir ce tableau sur la représentation
de l'espace social certains pour en
arriver à considérer cette imagerie
comme une boule de cristal permettant
d'identifier ce que chaque groupe aimera
ou n'aimera pas cette vidéo vise donc à
coller au plus près de l'écriture de
pierre bourdieu pour restituer de la
manière la plus claire mais aussi le
plus fidèlement possible et en toute
modestie
ce modèle de l'espace social présenté
dans cette oeuvre
que dis-je ce monument est la
distinction bourdieu dénonce la tendance
qui revient à représenter l'espace
social selon une seule dimension la
dimension économique
il observe d'ailleurs que le discours de
sens commun où le discours sociologique
quand ils utilisent des expressions
comme gravir l'échelle sociale
le déclin social l'ascension sociale
sont porteurs d'une représentation
verticale de l'espace social
unidimensionnel et continue pour lui
déterminé les classes sociales en
fonction d'une seule variable c'est
occulter finalement tout le réseau de
relations qu'il peut y avoir entre
différentes variables
même s'il en existe des principales et
d'autres qui sont secondaires bourdieu
dans la distinction tente ni plus ni
moins que de restituer toute la
complexité de l'espace social structuré
par différentes dimensions mise en
relation selon bourdieu l'espace social
est structurée par trois dimensions le
volume du capital la structure du
capital et l'évolution de ces deux
dimensions dans le temps la
différenciation des conditions de vie de
chaque individu dans l'espace social se
fait tout d'abord par la quantité de
ressources dont chacun dispose la
particularité du travail de pierre
bourdieu et de ne pas se limiter à la
seule composante économique puisqu'il
prend également en compte les ressources
culturelles sociales voire symbolique de
cette manière les personnes ayant
beaucoup de capitaux quel qu'il soit
font partie de la classe dominante
tandis que celles qui en sont dépourvus
composent les classes populaires
les classes moyennes sont quant à elles
moyennement dotées en capitaux de
toujours après avoir défini cette
dimension principal qui est rare chis
l'espace social
bourdieu en vient aux différences
secondaire à l'intérieur de chacune des
classes défini par le volume du capital
le type de capital que possède chaque
individu précis sa position dans
l'espace social bourdieu appelle cette
dimension la structure du capital
les personnes possédant plus de capitaux
économiques que de capitaux culturel se
regroupent d'un côté de l'espace social
tandis que celles qui disposent de plus
de capitaux culturel que de capitaux
économiques s'opposent sur l'espace
social à cette première catégorie
l'espace social et donc structuré selon
bourdieu en chiasme c'est à dire de
manière inversée au niveau de la
structure des capitaux
cela peut s'illustrer par différentes
statistiques fournies par pierre
bourdieu où l'on observe un renversement
au niveau de la détention du patrimoine
et des pratiques culturelles en fonction
de la fraction de classes envisagées par
exemple on constate une plus grande
proportion de patrons de l'industrie et
de commerces propriétaires de leur
logement que chez les professeurs
al'inverse une part plus importante des
professeurs visite plus régulièrement
les musées que les patrons de
l'industrie et du commerce au capital
économique d un s'oppose le capital
culturel des autres même s'ils ont tous
deux des capitaux économiques et
culturels il ne s'agit bien sûr là que
d'une illustration
étant donné que les variables prise en
considération ne sont pas univoques
elle exprime en même temps différent
capitaux pour aller au musée
il faudra avoir du capital culturel pour
comprendre ce que l'on va aller voir
mais également peut-être du capital
économique pour se déplacer et payer le
droit d'entrée de plus ces variables
recouvre des réalités parfois plus
subtile le théâtre d'avant-garde ou
classique
ce n'est pas la même chose que la
comédie de boulevard avec des célébrités
ce dernier genre de théâtre est
d'ailleurs plus prisés par la fraction
dominante à capitale économique élevée
des classes dominantes la fraction qui
occupent l'espace central de l'espace
des classes dominantes que l'on peut par
facilité associés aux professions
libérales est à la fois bien dotées en
capitaux économiques et en capitaux
culturel il utilise ses ressources pour
les transformer en capital social par la
consommation de certains biens
économiques et culturels
ce qui leur permet de maintenir leur
position et leur prestige social
la structure en chiasme s'observe aussi
pour les classes moyennes ou une partie
des classes moyennes sera plus richement
dotées en capitaux économiques qu'une
autre partie qui sera plus richement
dotées en capitaux culturel l'importance
d'un type de capital est très marquée
dans les processus de reproduction
sociale au sein de l'espace social
la domination permise par la détention
d'un capital plutôt qu'un autre est un
enjeu de lutte pour les différentes
fractions d'une même classe
chacune tente d'imposer et de limiter
l'accès à la ressource qu'elle possède
le plus afin de se maintenir socialement
par exemple les patrons de l'industrie
vont renâclé à soutenir des politiques
de financement des biens culturels des
productions culturelles voire la
production de capitaux scolaire ars
crainte de faire basculer le rapport de
force au profit de la fraction de la
classe dominante plus richement dotées
en capitaux culturel toutefois pierre
bourdieu ne voit pas l'espace social
comme un espace continue l'accès aux
capitaux n'est pas géographiquement
uniforme si bien que les disparités de
répartition spatiale des groupes dans
l'espace géographique se traduisent par
des ruptures et des barrières au sein
même de l'espace social par exemple les
agriculteurs qui vivent par définition
en milieu rural ont objectivement moins
de chances d'accéder à certains produits
culturels par absence de structures
culturelles dans les campagnes ils sont
donc pénalisés pour l'obtention de ce
type de capitaux les hiérarchies
sociales sont aussi derrière archi
géographique ce qui vient d'être dit
n'empêche toutefois pas la mobilité au
sein de l'espace social l'espace social
doit être conçue comme dynamique
c'est-à-dire que la position de chacun
gens mais aussi celle de chaque groupe
n'est pas figé et peut évoluer dans le
temps des déplacements verticaux sont
possibles dans une même colonne l'agent
voit son volume de capital augmenter ou
diminuer et peut donc aux gradés de
classe mais peut aussi perdre sa
position des déplacements horizontaux
peuvent se produire dans pour maintenir
sa position dans l'espace social
l'individu effectué une reconversion de
ces capitaux d'un type de capital vers
un autre type par exemple un guitariste
qui arrêterait la musique peut se
reconvertir sur youtube en proposant des
tutos de guitare sur une chaîne
à voir ça un certain nombre de vues les
monétiser et finalement gagner sa vie
avec cette chaîne
il a donc transformé un capital culturel
le fait de pouvoir jouer de la guitare
et de connaître la musique en un
capitale économique
il a reconverti ses capitaux à côté de
ces trajectoires individuelles
l'évolution du système social contraint
les fractions de classe à recombiner
continuellement les rapports qu'elles
ont les unes avec les autres afin de
conserver la valeur de leurs capitaux et
donc leur position sociale
bourdieu au moment de la distinction
observe que les classes dominantes de la
fraction la mieux dotée en capital
économie entre massivement en
concurrence dans le champ scolaire avec
l'autre fraction des classes dominantes
lui dotées en capitaux culturelles et
scolaires afin de garantir leur
reproduction désormais conditionnée par
l'obtention de certains titres en
réaction la fraction dominé des classes
dominantes va surenchérir au niveau des
titres scolaires cette course aux titres
scolaires conduit in fine et à une
dévaluation de certains titres et oblige
donc les agents à s'adapter à ce nouveau
changement
trois petits points 3 petits points et
trois petits points on comprend bien par
cet exemple que l'espace social est
traversée par des tensions conflictuelle
historique et symbolique auquel les
agents doivent apporter des réponses
sous peine d'être déclassé socialement
le volume et la structure des capitaux
ainsi que les relations que les
différentes classes vont avoir entre
elles sont continuellement chambouler
ses stratégies de reconversion des
capitaux sont plus ou moins subi plus ou
moins volontaire en fonction des groupes
pris en considération ces stratégies
conditionne des styles de vie des
différentes classes qui de ce fait sont
également en évolution constante au sein
de l'espace social à certains endroits
de l'espace on assiste à des
remplacements silencieux d'un groupe par
un autre à des déclassements
générationnel à des déplacements qui
parfois reste visible en raison de
l'inertie liées aux pratiques et aux
habitudes acquises dans le groupe social
d'origine à des sagas familiales
interrompue certains secteurs
professionnels sont propices aux coups
de force visant reconvertir du capital
d'un type dans un autre type produit
explique que certains secteurs notamment
liée au conseil créé du capital culturel
nouveau à partir d'un recyclage d'un
capital culturel de classe les exemples
qu'il donne comme
les professions touchant à l'image où
les conseillers conjugaux ne nous parle
plus aujourd'hui étant donné que ces
professions ont été depuis légitimé par
un cursus scolaire qui leur permet de
convertir de facto leur capital culturel
hérité en capital scolaire légitimer
mais on peut très bien imaginer de
nouvelles professions apparus depuis
comme les décorateurs d'intérieur les
coaches scolaire les relookeur de
meubles ou les formateurs en
développement personnel qui sont autant
d'occupations professionnels qui ne sont
pas encore tout à fait certifiable par
un parcours scolaire ou des agents
tentent en fait de recapitaliser dans
une forme socialement valorisables un
héritage culturel familial ou social
frappé par l'obsolescence parce qu'ils
sont dans des relations de tension les
uns par rapport aux autres
les groupes ou les agents sont sans
cesse contraint de changer pour
conserver leur position sociale qui
n'est défini que par rapport à celles
des autres lorsque l'on positionne les
individus dans l'espace social de
manière objective sur base de la
détention des différents capitaux il
apparaît que les caractéristiques comme
les professions le nombre d'enfants ne
sont pas réparties de manière aléatoire
dans l'espace social par exemple dans la
distinction bourdieu montre que les
employés de bureau ou les salariés
agricoles sont presque tous localisés
dans une même partie de l'espace social
mais bourdieu pousse l'analyse plus loin
encore
lorsqu'on se penche sur les préférences
culturelles les pratiques les biens
consommés les sports pratiqués le type
d'alimentation tout ce que bourdieu
appelle le style de vie on constate que
ces styles ne sont pas non plus
distribuée de manière aléatoire et
qu'une cohérence se dégage pour former
des styles de vie plus ou moins uniforme
selon la position occupée dans l'espace
social on le dire autrement des
conditions d'existence similaire
conduisent à adopter un style de vie
similaire bourdieu affirme donc qu'il
existe une homologie c'est à dire une
correspondance entre l'espace social et
l'espace des styles de vie à ce stade
mon dieu n'a encore rien expliqué il n'a
fait qu'établir avec profondeur et
élégance faut-il le reconnaître
un constat qui convient maintenant de
comprendre c'est ce qu'il fera avec son
concept d'habitus dont l'ombre n'a pas
cessé de planer sur nous tout au long de
cette vidéo et sur lequel nous
reviendrons prochainement
cette vidéo
terminé merci de l'avoir suivi et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur la société
[Musique]